hi everyone its Jonah here and today we
want to be tuning up on our arms and our
shoulders you'll need for this workout
is a mat and a chair but the end of this
video I want you to feel that your
shoulders and your arms are burning and
so so let's get started
so let's start the warm-up by doing few
punches so eight punches to the front
really click and pull your arms back and
it bunches up okay so pretty punch and
give it only ten go again and up yes
last time five six seven up yep and now
that's just like on our arms okay
make big circles to begin with two all
the way front you really feel your abs
muscle warming up okay all the way front
and now reverse cycle first you warming
up our unsub video shoulders and to your
arms okay
and now just forward again but small
circles so really small circles and just
go forward
really funny and now reverse all right
keep going and get yourself the first
workout what I want you to do is to step
and the edge of your mats and what we
want to do is call each word so place it
put it down okay with your knees
straight with your pump up and all we
want to do is deserting each forwards to
the end of the match
so that's inch forward how are you to
open up it comes and work on the back
part of your shoulder reach forward open
up the other side edge forward open it
up open you can see legs if you go as
far as you can get and now same thing
we're going to first going back get you
should also feel your core or 18 and
same time go clean up squeeze the thighs
party showed us in changing changing
inch backwards and now when you're here
I want you to spread it out slightly and
just do four shoulder presses with me so
hexam push it back up down again up down
down and good now we're going to repeat
the same thing second time come in for
it open and squeeze the back part of the
shoulders good keep going
fabulous because at the same time you're
right on the edge of the net
and reverse comeback now let's go good
point you plot upwards really feel your
upper body
you showed us an ounce working keep
going back now that you're here what are
we doing still show the practice go one
two three four once more let's inch go
open up good try not to cheat little by
little do you feel your body working do
for your shoulders and arms burning yes
and reverse let's go keep going you're
doing it
open up
[Music]
last one and let's go to show the
process 1 2 3 4 and just drop down and
relax for one to stretch upper body out
he'll jump the owner that the next
workout is time for marquisha signature
which opposition
okay on your toes and whatever you to do
is to imitate a diamond position and
push your body back out alright so let's
do three of those down with your partner
- but up really ties one more and we're
going down on to the next straight body
okay that's one set every doing three
sets
so again tuck your toes in push my body
up go and let's go voila
die yeah good see you
this is really challenging and three and
bring your body back down good job
normal cell if you find this challenging
you can always start on your knees okay
let's go
anybody up da once more
[Music]
and please and realize oh my god that
was tough just relax and stretch your
upper body arms and now what we want to
do is to work on our triceps so this is
a tricep pushup and we'll be doing it on
our knees instead of a normal push-up
position
but is quite wide for tricep push-ups
what you want to do is you bring both
arms lose your chest with an almost
facing back okay so let's do this you
want to start up and let's do chopped
down to three very good for you lose
myself earning five six halfway there
seven breda shellfish my steps eight
nine ten two more seven attacks one last
one - good give job
all this workout are really shot but
they are really effective your arms and
your shoulders I'm showing you through
that right now
and for the final workout grab a chair
we're going to do this triceps dips for
tricep big place both arms on the chair
with real thing is facing forward
the further your legs are the harder it
is so if you want to start with an
easier version bend your knees and bring
your body close together and just look
down and up what we want to do is to
make sure that your body is as close to
the chair as possible so that is wrong
pretty picture
bring it down and up so let's do travel
this for the harder version Green Onyx
external links to their way all right
ready that's good
it's you working on your triceps and
also your shoulders and a little bit
onto the chair chess so really place
your chair securely to the world buy
more one good job two three four
and five good if you can try not to use
a studio chat because it's gonna move
about and just rest and just drag your
arms out
because what we want to do is the second
sex ready which are chatter sighs get on
to your mat and let's start sorry really
where ii said let's start with inchworm
down again go to the end of the but we
squeeze the back of the shoulder and
rivers let's go inch do a good job
body working
okay and i'll stay there and that's so
low shoulder presses one two three four
fold again go doing very well I know
it's not easy because I will show us and
our lungs muscles have very small
therefore usually they are much quicker
okay but that doesn't mean we should
have turned that up let's go small this
is torturous but
you will do sense wife and enemies that
will show depresses one hit down two
three four one more set go
so we stopped down keep going
no do not drop onto the mat not just yet
if I'm doing it you're doing it with me
let's go as far as you can go but it's
not easy this communities well become
stop feeling so slow right now
all right shoulder presses for success
here one two three four good job no crap
you've shot rest and now let's get into
a push-up position
if you want you can always stop on your
knees okay I'm gonna do it on my knees
in the first set and just do three sets
ready to dive in or we don't push up one
more down and just relax all the way sir
okay let's do it on our toes right now
ready girls
that's it one two up three times
- good 300 down one more set
three times let's hear it Susie I push
it up one two their last one oh my god
well done well done and loop it and same
thing get into your recipe precision
hurry quickly and now let's go straight
into tricep push-ups so underneath
what's your legs remember what we
promised your chest and we are focusing
solely on our triceps ready let's start
up and let's do travel them all right
[Music]
three four six one together five six
halfway there
seven eight doing so well formal knowing
come on come on don't stop now last one
one more and to give Respighi game again
and now grab your chest so I really
choose the intensity we want to work
with place both hands extend your legs
all the way and your child comes and
this is your last one two three jump
four five if you're feeling strong you
can do another step if you want to get
your cup with that let's go try to keep
your text eddie- moving about last three
one two
really push it up with your prices go
home well well done so just sit in the
chair and we're just gonna do some
gentle stretches for your arms so just
through the other side across this is to
pressure Cheryl okay arms Warka are not
easy and wasn't completing the whole set
and the other side
and if you can't do this three times a
week together toward arms minimum at
least twice a week so just stretch it
back that's very tricep really keep your
body straight extend all the way and yet
sight good job I'm noticing when I'm
working out and now just place both
thumbs facing down and just stretch back
to stretch your entire arms just slowly
stretch back and relax remember when
you're whenever you're stretching you
just relax try not to tense your muscles
Harper and well done
so that was my arms and showed us work
out if they're not easy they are
challenging even for me keep doing it
keep progressing and you'll find that it
would get easier try to do it two to
three times per week and give it six
weeks to see the difference don't forget
to like this video share this video
workout with the girlfriends do you
check out my Facebook and Instagram
because that's where I'll update myself
daily and please do subscribe to my
youtube channel for more fitness and
nutritional videos
you